welcome to this video and Bashir leave
the opponent here and he's from
Azerbaijan right yes I got one right
okay let's play the Bishop f5 line for a
change nah I'm sorry my code really has
gotten better but sometimes it still
sounds like I'm on my last legs okay
that seemed it's not playing age for
yeah this is in fact somewhat in precise
move order because of the early c5 and
I'm going to use this opportunity it's
better for white to change early night
to be fine okay so check interesting
yeah that's I don't mind the Queen's
rate of course check yeah I had a very
similar position recently and turn again
I get this good structure with um the
policy for the question be five or not
be five okay let's do that not not the
only way to play the even see three was
interesting but this looks nice what I
want to do is want to secure the d5
square and I will play 95 next move
almost no matter what he's doing yep
that's a nice post the only issue is the
bishop on e5 had always pressure rising
the g7 pond and I'm not sure I want to
play f6 put even more parts on dark
squares it's not turn not so great I
wonder I wonder how to play that night
air for yeah maybe I can just take play
rook the ad five so we place this and
okay this is surprising
ok so now I'll our chains I change Ted
here f6 pushing the bishop away and then
try to gain even more spatium night f4 I
have Knight c3 all the bishop check
first yeah i guess the bishop check
first try to get an attack here with a 4
and it's taking some time and maybe a
rupee one would I have two should be
four mmm differ God or maybe you should
just play C 3 but I can take on b3 play
a phone mmm yeah tricky very tricky
position I understand that he's taking
some time I'm also not sure what you
should do
I still feel finish you should try to
get something against yeah let's say six
now this is this is a possibility of
course I thought to take and play for
could be a could be an option yeah I'll
do that not invest any more time yeah
yeah I could also take and then play 9
p-6 here now needs to play c5 which I'm
not sure he wants to do she likes to do
yeah all exactly that one and this is
just check just tricky now yeah I can I
could advance but let's let's play it
simple yeah but I can take it the
bushido evade yeah he probably just
overlooked that I can take this wasn't
clear at all at least I don't don't
think it was okay
hmm still not so so easy
I have still have slight coordination
issues okay but now I think I'm fine
rookie 2 and the night the night
actually has no square check yeah it
didn't have any scram check okay what's
the easiest i guess a tune yeah i just
need to to get a check on c3
yeah okay a key can take on c5 if he
doesn't yeah well he yes no
yeah maybe just just take this and
played you too yeah there's no there's
no staying made simply yes then has a
jeep on check yeah he's got King be to
all the time so I can just just take
this checkmate yeah this was very
similar to a game that I had met on
recently where I got the strong be five
square after c4 and this looks quite
comfortable already and am only a couple
of moves later it really looked like a
very very nice position and here i had
multiple good ideas also Bishop e3 check
is a good move but ok this this was it
was ok not turn not doing a mistake yeah
this is check I think it probably needs
to play c5 check this is not really a
really working I mean this is also
nothing for white I can he can go here I
just had this important check out the
time after which the King doesn't have a
good square is very easy and therefore
he needs to go somewhere yeah somewhere
stupid like 92 and black is is just just
winning yam he directly I think in the
opening he needs to prove he wasn't
losing or anything directly but around
here the screen b5 check already a she's
very check this is already very
accommodating like a instantly ass got a
good game here okay thanks for watching